you can tell everybody you're Italian
I hear about Caroline she's a [__]
phony and you're doing and telling
things going look at me come on like
look at this oh look at it I tied a god
[Music]
so there's a Reuters investigation that
just revealed
that over a hundred U.S government
officials from both sides all right it's
not just Republicans besides okay both
sides all sides actually including
independent and every living former U.S
president
except for Trump is a direct descendant
from slaveholders
Wow except for Trump oh that makes sense
his family is a new immigrant yeah
because they weren't here because his uh
grandfather is an immigrant because
they're new money probably huh well
they're not they're they weren't from
America originally no it was just great
they were first not that anyone was but
like no yeah I think it was actually his
grandfather his grandfather's from
the Netherlands or something so they
didn't his family didn't arrive in U.S
until after abolition so
um but every other
living president even Obama yeah yeah
his white side damn they ruined it yeah
it's it's a well come on here he's
related to safeholders too really yeah I
remember that being mind-blowing too
[__] yeah because what is she is she
she's halfway she's half black and
Indian no yeah no this can't make any
sense you know why because the Asian
Senators had there's no way they own
slaves it says out of um it doesn't say
all Senators it's all five living
presidents two supreme court justices 11
Governors and 100 legislators oh okay
all these people that are currently in
the government I thought you met all
senators and all like right yeah no that
wouldn't we know that had slaves
in in all of history
except other Asians
is that bad
isn't it a thing that like Korea was the
longest country to still maintain
slavery was it I think they maintain or
they were they still do it but they
still did it like way the [__] out
really I think yeah they got rid of it
in the 90s or some [__] like black guys
like me oh yeah for sure but yeah in
terms of like lawmakers and all these
people in the government on both sides
both sides both sides I do know a lot of
the like super high level politician
it's like you know you have like your
boys club and a lot of them are like
generational because of the roots that
they have so it's easier to just extend
the Legacy like if your dad was [__]
I don't know like James or your great
grandpa's like James Madison or some
[__] then they went to like I don't know
Yale so you go to Yale and then you
already have the connects to be on the
fast track to do whatever so for people
that want to be like new family I mean
like New Politics we would probably
start at the local level and I'd
probably get I don't know maybe to the
state level then it's easier to kind of
give taika a leg up and the Titan give
his kid like up into the federal yeah
and by the time they're there they're
kind of encouraging their family to kind
of be really really what's the thing
it's called endowments too it's like you
know if you went to Yale right yeah and
then you're you've been donating to Yale
now we all know your kids getting into
Yale that's just how it works it's like
a whole thing yeah that's true now they
all know which schools to go to like
this kid's gonna go to West Point
because of this or like you know they
all it's like a big Network that they
just passed down if you're if you're
like the elite families even during like
colonial times in New England
doesn't that make sense like you stay in
the community for Generations it's
almost like a small town of people that
all knew each other so I'm like why why
is that a conspiracy that makes sense
what's a conspiracy all the people that
are like ruling like the aristocrats of
America are like all these like they're
related the people who say it's the
conspiracy or the aristor of the
aristocrats yeah it's it's yeah the rest
of us are like yeah we see it it's very
like I think I think what it points out
is that like there's no there's no room
to call out descendants of slave owners
specifically because
both sides come from that yeah yeah but
it's a it's a nice little hot button
topic to be like your family owned
slaves yeah it's really confusing
because the KKK were a part of the
Democratic Party
a lot of people don't know that nobody
wants to know that yeah I mean Abraham
Lincoln is a republican he freed the
slaves right but
the difference is over time humans are
constantly being born and dying so
different groups take over the left and
the right all the time yeah it's like
switching it's not the same exact group
every single time so like
they can't really snapshot a piece of
history and be like oh you see this is
this group and it's like well it's a
different group now and it's just
continuously going to keep changing
right
that kind of in a way kind of eliminates
that as part of the conversation in
terms of like who should be disqualified
because their lineage was X or Y it's
kind of like hey I mean if that was
America at a point and your ancestry
does go back that far chances are you
probably benefited from it yeah if this
was school yard [__] though like kids at
a schoolyard it's a little bit of a
different conversation isn't it it's
like dude my ancestors ripped the [__]
out of your ancestors [__]
completely changes the topic doesn't it
like you use it as a as leverage against
the other person versus yeah versus the
way it is now where we're all like oh
yeah that sucks and so I'm sorry but
when you're a kid you just want to
[__] win the argument yeah yeah
maybe in the 90s and 2000s that's true I
feel like now everybody's well
it's like um
how do you well so the thing is like a
lot of these people might even be like
oh thanks for doing the lineage thing I
had no idea it takes about I want to say
three generations maxed till you're
estranged with your own history or like
some people don't even know like what if
you're born out of wedlock and you do
have a lineage to this family but you're
like estranged like what happens to them
yeah like should you should those stains
follow you you're still a slave owner
that's what yeah or you're the opposite
of what's the opposite of strange where
you get [__] attached and you don't
even know like our Guilty By Association
like one of our friends is a interior
designer and then uh her whole life her
grandma was like oh what's up you do
this thing because it's Italian thing
it's Italian thing whatever right and
then she did like 23andMe and found out
she's actually like Colombian and then
it was like something about like her
what who she thought her Grandpa was
wasn't even her Grandpa and then she was
like but wait Grandma you knew that
so why would you still tell me it was an
Italian day when you knew I was like
half Colombian the whole time so it's
like her whole but that shifted her
whole identity because she always like
for the last 40 years thought she was
[__] that is that would be a weird
identity crisis isn't that crazy she
thought she's Italian for 40 years you
embrace your culture your whole life
yeah you tell everybody you're Italian
you hear about Caroline she's a [__]
phony and you're doing Italian things
going look at me come on like look at
this oh look at it I tied a garlic not
perfect
oh I hand make my own pasta thank you
that's so crazy you're just Colombian
the whole time that's a pretty big I'm
actually Hispanic what the [__] yeah but
then there's little hints sometimes you
have someone's pasta and you're like oh
this must be him and they're like no
it's like those [__] there's all they
had to soften and it's not even like
close like if you were like oh I'm not
Sicilian I'm just regular Italian
because it's all imagine like how many
of those there are too you know where
it's like their their families with like
artificially joined together but not
even but what about like you're if
you're you're dad's O.J Simpson are you
like a [__] [__] yeah you know
what I mean like like why are we doing
this [__] about Generations ago like
some people had [__] up parents right
now who everyone knows like they're
probably murders or whatever but people
aren't like oh OJ's kids that's [__]
up you're [__] up would you hang out
with OJ's kid exactly of course I would
you're a product of your history yeah
because what exactly I want to find out
who the real killer is
it's a beautiful topic though because
there's nothing you can do about it
except argue there's nothing you do
forever because most people have empathy
for kids who grew up in a [__] up like
your parents are criminals it's like
poor you so it's like if your
grandparents had that stain isn't it
like poor you also because it's like
yeah it's like dude they they were born
into that family do you think they
wanted to right I think the main
argument that I've heard is that these
people are in the exact position they
are in life because at some point
somebody had it really good yeah so
they're benefiting on the trickle-down
generationally they're like oh you're
not going to hear me defend politicians
my friend I'm with you whatever you want
but at the same time it's like okay but
what are you gonna do about it
that is yeah right it's like it's like
okay yeah they're they've benefited so
it's like are you gonna you're gonna
kill their all [__] family well and
we're this we're the Schmucks who like
every time these guys get elected right
we are the ones who reelect them every
[__] time exactly because I'm like
exactly they're not waiting for no
reason they're getting voted in Eighty
percent of the incumbents get reelected
yeah we keep doing it right so it's like
are you participating in the system
voting because a lot of people that do
comment they're not voting yeah right
dude I comment all the time I haven't
voted and I don't know how long that's
also not a disqualifying prerequisite
like it's not like they're going oh
you're not eligible to run for governor
because you have
a slave owner in your genealogy it's not
yeah it doesn't disqualify you I don't
know so bringing it up is kind of like
well what does that do actually I don't
understand why right now it's this weird
time where you can't judge a
individual's character and like
see their track record but you just it's
like you don't even see them as a human
being you see them as like a caricature
of what you want to believe like this is
an Asian guy or whatever a white like
slave owner or whatever right but it's
like
they're they're like it's like what
about what what have they done in the
past and if they've done criminal [__]
then yeah like we should regulate but if
they have a clean record and you know
they're just politicking and it's like
what's the agenda right we need to argue
with each other about meaningless things
like if your kids if your your children
are innocent of the things that you have
done and yet we do this [__] about
certain topics but not others like your
dad could have been a murderer your mom
could have like drowned a a kid but
nobody cares about that nobody like
nobody's like I can't eat with you
because of that yeah but if it's cherry
picking yeah Hitler had kids right
should we execute them exactly it's like
that we should consider isn't there
something in China where like you have
to pay the debt of your parent if they
[__] up or something I think it's like
it's three generations I think that's
North Korea that's North Korea only no
they have some kind of weird [__] where
your whole family gets [__] up yeah oh
well yeah they they just yeah wipe you
out yeah but it's like a generation
isn't there something monetarily like
like if you died with owing money like
crazy it doesn't just disappear in Asia
certain countries that I don't know
because here it's just gone right yeah I
think if you die in your lower debt yeah
I think I thought it gets passed down to
the kids no because you can't like
that's why they don't give you can't be
99 and sign up for life insurance
because you're gonna die tomorrow I'm
gonna pay you like a million dollars you
can be 50 instead of life insurance
sometimes man yeah my old man just had
to give up life insurance because he's
like they keep on raising the rates on
me
he's been bait for like 25 years I think
he finally just [__] gave up he's
like they're raising it through the
goddamn room did he get anything back no
I'm getting priced out of my own life
it's insane he just paid all that money
and then it just yes for nothing how
much do you think it was total I had to
be I mean I had to be hundreds and
hundreds of thousands yeah so he doesn't
get any of it I don't think so he didn't
he certainly didn't brag about it on the
phone seemed pretty pissed maybe he
doesn't he doesn't want you to have any
of it it could be the story off the set
[Music]